get it Batman it's good to see you
playing well with others again just like
a bat a dig it may be temporary
[Music]
Harlequin
they became the king and queen of Gotham
City
see youtubers is Charlie so we got to
talk about Batman working with other
people again some and talk all about
Nightwing the Robins here we go I know
everybody is wondering where Superman is
that's why they put Lois Lane in the
trailer to remind you that Superman will
appear we can talk about him in another
video but that injustice to video game
giveaway that I'm doing is still going
on so all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video working with other people such a
throwaway line but such a big loaded
comment so I mean when we're reading Jim
Gordon for the first time the new
version of Jim Gordon I still totally
see him as Jay jonah Jameson he has not
aged a day
since he did those Tobey Maguire
spider-man movies but here's where we
get to the timeline because they just
announced a Nightwing movie meaning the
Dick Grayson is still alive so you're
like okay who's the dead Robin that we
saw in Batman V Superman are they really
going to do under the Red Hood will we
see a version of Jason Todd in the
universe so the thing about big DC
world-building movies like this they're
building a big film universe is that
everything is possible until it isn't
possible so until VAX matter the
producers come out and say no this Robin
is dead we're never going to do him it's
sort of an unspoken rule that there's
infinite potential for anything that
seems pretty simple to do like logically
it makes sense that this dead Robin here
was Jason Todd so they will do that
comic book arc eventually but when you
think about the timeline so Batman like
I said is in his 40s you have to imagine
that the Christian Bale version of the
character was someone in his late 20s I
mean that franchise spans several years
so he was much older by the time he
stopped being Batman Michael Keaton's
version was someone I always saw as
being in his 30s and they never really
did the Robins during the Michael Keaton
era I don't treat the Joel Schumacher
films as canon they're just kind of like
off by themselves so the real clues
about what happened to that Robin and
what the timeline is is when we got the
Suicide Squad and we saw that card for
Harley Quinn where it is the one of the
crimes that she had been arrested for
was the death of one of the Robins her
involvement with the Joker in killing
that version of the Robin so it makes
sense that the Ben Affleck version of
the character in his late 20s took on
the Dick Grayson Robin he eventually
grew up became Nightwing in his 30s he
took on the Jason Todd versions of the
characters they had their DC EU version
of a
in the family because Harley Quinn
didn't exist in the comics when does in
the family was happening she was created
later for the animated series then
written into a comic book then written
into the larger canon of the actual
mainstream comics so Harley his path to
the DC EU which is a little bit
different than some of the other core
Batman characters but true to fashion
when Batman V Superman was getting ready
to come out and we saw the uniform they
were very opaque about what was going on
it was just that Batman had suffered a
death in the family in all the years of
crime-fighting all the darkness that he
had encountered had just piled on his
soul and he had hung up the cape and
cowl until this Superman event happened
and he's like okay that is it this is
where the line is drawn I'm putting the
cape and cowl back on so that's where we
arrived at Justice League when he goes
to assemble this team you get to this
Gordon quote hey it's good to see you
working with other people again so this
whole time that he's hung up the cape
and cowl you have to assume that the
Dick Grayson Nightwing was active in
Bludhaven
which is where his movie is going to
take place they haven't said anything
about what the plot is going to be but I
do love the idea that they could
resurface adjacent Tod somewhere in
there so they could do a Batman team-up
movie like a Justice League style Batman
family movie way down the road I know a
lot of you are asking about the backdoor
Nightwing version of Batman in case Ben
Affleck ever leaves like if Warner
Brothers is building themselves an
option in case Ben Affleck is like okay
you know I did my Batman solo movie it's
2019 I don't want to do any more I don't
think that's going to happen because I
think that Justice League trailer
there's always going to be people that
don't like DC movies no matter what but
I feel like that trailer did a good job
of healing a lot of the damage that
Suicide Squad and Batman V Superman did
in the fandom so now everybody's a
little more optimistic than they used to
be so I think that will trickle down to
Ben Affleck and he will stick around for
another Justice League film because Zack
Snyder is not going to be doing it they
already confirmed that another director
is going to do the next Man of Steel
movie Zack Snyder did the first Man of
Steel movie that was sort of the
beginning of the DC EU so he's slowly
fading into the background Zack Snyder
is going to be done and new people will
come in there were a couple years when
Warner Brothers was not doing so well
financially Batman V Superman and
Suicide Squad had to do really well and
they did make a lot of money for Warner
Brothers so they kind of skated by but
the
things that they need to do is a solid
franchise even if you make a halfway
good Batman movie people will go see it
but what's the greatest safest bet that
you could possibly make if Batman is
your biggest character is you do a big
Batman family team up with other
characters Avengers style after setting
them up like you do a Nightwing movie
like you would do a solo Avengers film
then eventually you collect these Batman
characters together you put some of the
people from Suicide Squad like Harley
Quinn in it and I wouldn't say you do
batter for the cow but you could do a
big grand Avengers style justice league
level story like hush which involves a
ton of Batman characters in a way that a
more intimate Batman movie wouldn't I
think largely based on the success of
Deadpool and Logan people are more
excited about smaller comic book films
so I wouldn't expect Batman films to get
bigger and bigger and bigger but that
doesn't mean that they couldn't do it
after doing their Nightwing solo felt
now that all just depends on how that
turns out if it's a good movie people
love it they'll do more Nightwing solo
movies but let me know in the comments
would you actually want to see them do a
Batman family team up movie and just do
like a really big Batman story from the
comics they always change the comic book
story a little bit but what if they were
to work their way up to Batman under the
Red Hood a big live-action treatment of
that they might have to change the title
a little bit but it's the same idea you
introduced the Red Hood character the
former version of Robin to the universe
and he becomes something of an
antagonist and antihero who works with
Batman sometimes but also hates the crap
out of them so he's just a really
interesting character he's like the
manifestation of Batman's guilt how dare
I think it was safe to put a kid out on
the streets fighting crime that was sort
of the lasting impact of his death it
was like hey what would happen if you
took a kid out fighting crime every
night he would probably end up dead
the reason Damian Wayne works so well is
one because it's fun that Batman has a
biological child who also shares DNA
with his most hated enemy and has the
training of a full member of the League
of Assassins I was like okay Damian
Wayne is a little kid but he could
probably handle himself even without
superpowers but I don't think there are
any plans for like a big Batman family
team up movie as of right now just
mostly focusing on getting Justice
League out doing a really good job with
that fixing them
and of Steel franchise because he's kind
of an underserved character right now
Henry Cavill just had to spend eight
months pretending like he's not doing
any other movies even though we all know
that he's in Justice League so there are
a couple reckonings that they have to
address in the batman movies and i think
they'll save them for the batman movies
one is the Joker killing the Robin with
Harley Quinn
she obviously regrets it he probably
does not so they will have their
come-to-jesus moment with the bat God
where he judges them and then when later
you know big surprise we find out that
Jason Todd has been resurrected and now
he really hates Batman there's just so
much great Batman family drama that they
could do on screens it would make for
amazing movies so let me know in the
comments where do you want them to take
this and unfortunately a lot of it just
depends on how the next couple of movies
do and how long Ben Affleck wants to
stay
I do think he'll stay through that
second Justice League film which I
believe is 2020 right now is the
tentative release date for that but
after that it's anyone's game in the
next Batman movie that he's doing won't
come out to about 2019 so I think if
they were to do a follow-up under the
Red Hood team-up movie with the Batman
family we wouldn't see it to like 20 21
or even beyond that so anything could
happen but I think that'll be fine this
year I think that Wonder Woman will do
great I think Justice League will do
fine 20 that'll give Ben Affleck and
Warner Brothers some of the emotional
and financial bump that they need to
keep pursuing this character so my next
video is going to be all about
spider-man homecoming they've been
teasing him with the Avengers building
in all these posters there is definitely
going to be a Spider Man trailer
sometime in the next week Tom Holland
posted this message here once your front
I'm Tom hall and your friendly
neighborhood fireman thank you so much
for liking our Facebook page and we hope
you like all the new content will be
posted over the next few days merci
beaucoup
that'll post in the morning then I'll do
some new Game of Thrones then there's a
new Walking Dead episode we're almost at
the finale of that so I'll say
congratulations to Elijah Harper you're
the new injustice giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video all announced the winner the next
time I post a DC video while you wait to
that click here to rewatch that Justice
League trailer a billion more times and
you can click here for brand-new
guardians of the
see in Sylvester Stalone secret
character thank you so much watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you